get ready to dive into the battlefield
in for honor master the medieval
weaponry as the bold Knights brutal
Vikings and lethal samurai prepare for
vicious fast-paced melee combat and
become the ultimate warrior but which of
the three legendary factions will you
choose here's what you need to know to
win glory as the Knights brought to you
by for honor the Knights of ash felled
were sent by the iron legions to pacify
the land they believed that the ancient
ruins that cover their lands were built
by their ancestors of the great Empire
scattered for centuries they have now
corralled under a single banner by
Asheville's black stone legion in
joining the Knights of the iron Legion
you select from heroes that are powerful
highly skilled and deadly you get the
chance to wield massive swords flails or
a sword and dagger combination Master
the Knights in order to take down the
Vikings and Samurai here's what we know
about Knights subclasses so far the
wardens are jack of all trade Knights
that are easy to use for beginners they
strike a balance between defense and
offense and feature a wide range of
basic abilities wardens wear partial
plate armor with chainmail and leather
and wield massive two-handed long swords
wardens are best with light quick
attacks especially against light heroes
their heavy swings pack a punch however
the time it takes to swing leaves them
wide open and easy to counter-attack
warden light attacks are too quick to
block if done right and our best by
doing dueling down your opponent's
health for one heavy finishing strike
combining one heavy attack followed by a
string of light quick attacks will keep
your opponent on their toes and under
your control with Swift sword attacks
and heavy armor to protect you enemies
such as the samurai won't stand a chance
conquerors are defensive fighters
recommended for playing at medium
difficulty they are heavily armored and
armed with massive flails they
destabilize opponents through multiple
defensive abilities the conqueror is an
excellent blocker with high attack
strength and heavy damage to back it up
thanks to their large shield conquerors
can block a little faster than other
heroes the downside to being a great
defensive character is that conquerors
lengthy wind-ups make it easy for more
nimble classes to dodge but if timed
right a block followed by a stun attack
will allow any conqueror to move in with
a few heavy swings before an opponent
can recover the Vikings Raider will fall
to their knees to the combined might of
your shield and skull shattering flail
the mid-level peacekeepers are fast and
lethal they use a combination of a sword
and dagger to inflict lead damage they
have limited range but high mobility
peacekeepers are hit-and-run masters on
the battlefield able to take capture
points more quickly and harass enemies
with quick cuts and fast dodging be
aware that peacekeepers have low armor
and just a few heavy hits will finish
one off light attacks followed by your
stun ability will keep an opponent off
their game allowing you to dodge attacks
with ease and finish them off with a
heavy strike soon we will learn about
the newest subclass of the Nights the
law bringers pledged your sword to the
Knights of the iron Legion and join the
war of the factions be sure to check out
our other videos to learn about the
other factions samurai and Vikings
brought to you by for honor for honor is
available on February 14th 2017 and for
all your for honor needs stick with
GameSpot